à chaque fois que les températures
montent de cette manière on pense bien
sûr aux plus fragiles aux personnes
âgées on vous le disais déjà hier il
faut boire il faut se protéger du soleil
mais c'est vrai que c'est important que
ce problème
non mais c'est pourquoi
je vais juste prince est une question
orale ring vous trouvez pas qu'il a une
tête de cocu et bien vous savez quoi
non parce que moi de toute façon je
laime quoi qu'il fasse la galoche lala
tant que ça au nom des enfants qui nous
regardent
attentat de temps est ce qu elle venue
elle veut se laver les dents les autres
lui la veille cloche alors un petit
bijou comme ça l'a avalé le smac housse
manger la bouche et la marocaine olala
jean-michel petit peu de respect valérie
je suis désolé de ce qu'il a fait nommer
duire vraiment quelle rat mort si si